this hit
goes out to you Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
And So It Begins it's been nine years
since Keanu Reeves John Wick went on a
rampage after a bunch of baddies broke
into his house and killed his puppy
and his taste for Revenge has not
changed much who's returning the
franchise who's new and how will Keanu
survive here's everything we need to
know before you go
since the first film premiered in 2014
director Chad stachelski's John Wick has
quickly become a cult classic and it
began something of a modern Keanu Sans
that continued with John Wick chapter 2
and John Wick chapter 3 Parabellum
foreign
so what's happened so far in the
franchise after retired Hitman John Wick
is forced back into the criminal
underworld he abandoned thanks to some
puppy-killing Russian gangsters Wick is
caught between returning to a life of
crime and escaping the 14 million bounty
on his life the last time we saw Wick
was in Parabellum when he was being
double-crossed by Winston played by Ian
McShane who shot Wick right off the roof
miraculously Mr Wick survives and we see
him delivered to the Bowery King played
by Lawrence Fishburne while there Wick
agrees to team up with the Bowery King
to take down the high table
and they about to find out if you cut a
King you better cut him to the quick
what could we expect to see in the
fourth installment the official synopsis
of John Wick chapter 4 reads John Wick
uncovers a path to defeating the high
table but before he can earn his freedom
Wick must face off against a new enemy
with powerful alliances across the globe
and forces that turn old friends into
foes I'm going to need a gun
we can expect lots of action scenes and
gunfu style choreography with stahlski's
signature written all over it we're
shooting and doing all the stuff as
we're going as he's drifting a car which
I think is pretty cool and then when he
gets out of the car he's having his
fight tactical sequence in and amongst
live traffic because there's other games
coming after me because there's all
kinds there's an open contract on John
Wick we've done the massive Gauntlet
it's a government probably the most
logistical tricky one
yeah you don't want to hit John
with the bus yeah but a lot of people
are getting hit by cars we have a line
in the air and shooting members shooting
at me a lot of stunt guys getting hit by
cars
stahlski also hints at an unhappy ending
for John Wick at the end of chapter four
he's quoted as saying do you think he's
gonna write off into the effing Sunset
he's killed 300 effing people and he's
just gonna walk away like everything's
okay he's eped for the rest of his life
it's just a matter of time amen
cast John Wick chapter 4 will feature an
incredible new cast including Ip Man
icon Donnie Yen who plays Kane one of
Jon's old assassin buds the trailer
indicates there will be a scene where
they try to kill each other which is
bound to be action-packed Japanese
Legend hiroyoki Sanada also stars as
shimazu while Japanese British pop star
Rina sawayama joins the cast in her
feature acting debut Bill Skarsgard
steps in as the new Baddie Marquis De
gramonte who offers Jon his freedom from
the high table if he defeats him in
combat
pistols
dueling pistols
30 paces
it was announced back in August 2020
that John Wick chapter 4 and chapter 5
were set to film back to back however
due to covid-19 and reef schedule with
the Matrix resurrections the sequels
ended up not filming back to back and
Lionsgate decided to only move forward
with John Wick chapter 4. it seems as
long as Keanu is up for playing the
titular Deadly Assassin with the
effortless hair we can expect to see
more John Wick movies in the future so
now you know and now you can go see John
Wick chapter 4 in theaters March 24th
after you've seen John Wick chapter 4 be
sure to rate and review it at
rottentomatoes.com